SPEAK OF THE CHRIS IS FORCED ON.
.2 INCLUDES OVER A HALF MILLION
CHILDREN.
MY MOTHER-IN-LAW MADE HER ESCAPE
FROM UKRAINE, ARRIVING IN POLAND
YESTERDAY.
REUNITED WITH HER DAUGHTER, MY
WIFE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WHAT WAS IT LIKE WAITING?
>> IT WAS ABSOLUTELY AWFUL.
BUT, I'M SO HAPPY.
BUT --
[LAUGHTER]
>> TURN IT UP, SHE SAYS!
THAT WAS ARROGANT.
[LAUGHTER]
STILL WEARING THEIR MASKS.
OR TURN COUNTRY FOR TWO DAYS, I
THINK YOU CAN PROBABLY TAKE OFF
YOUR MASK.
THIS WAS THANKS TO MIKE GRIEBEL
COLEY -- AND WHO YOU ARE THERE
INTERVIEWING WIFE.
SHE WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO MAKE
IT THERE TO SAFETY, BUT THERE
ARE STILL MILLIONS IN DANGER.
>> THIS IS WHY WE CROSS INTO
ANOTHER COUNTRY.
>> MY COLLEAGUES WERE SHOT BY
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS, THAT WAS WHEN
SHE TRIED TO LEAVE KIEV.
SHE IS DEAD.
>> JUST WANT TO PROTECT MY SON.
>> DID YOU LEAVE BEHIND?
>> IN THE FACE OF EVIL, THERE'S
STILL GOOD IN THE WORLD.
HEROES EVERYWHERE RISKING THEIR
LIVES TO LEAD OTHERS TO SAFETY.
CHERRIES LIKE PROJECT DYNAMO,
RESCUING PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS FIGHTING, GETTING THEM OUT
OF THE COUNTRY.
UBER IS OFFERING FREE RIDES
BETWEEN THEY ARE IN THE
UKRAINIAN BORDER, ALTHOUGH THEY
WON'T DRIVE YOU THERE BECAUSE IT
WILL START RAINING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GOOD FOR YOU!
>> WHO ARE YOU GOING TO RESCUE?
>> MYSELF.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE NEED A FOX NEWS ALERT FOR
THAT.
THAT WAS POSSIBLE.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT HAPPENED WITH YOU AND YOUR
ENTIRE FAMILY, I THINK YOU
SHOULD THROW A PARTY FOR
EVERYONE TO GET BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
WAS, I WANT TO MAKE A JOKE, BUT
I DON'T THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE,
SO I WON'T.
YOU'RE RIGHT, SHE'S NOT ALWAYS
HAPPY PERSONALLY.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M GLAD YOU CAN FINALLY MAKE
HER HAPPY.
>> AWW.
>> CLOSER TO THE TRUTH THAN YOU
MIGHT EXPECT.
[LAUGHTER]
WE KNOW THERE ARE PEOPLE WITH
THEIR GRANDMOTHERS, AND WHAT DO
THEY DO?
PROJECT DYNAMO IS ONE.
THEY HAD GONE TO AFGHANISTAN >>
THERE'S SO MANY ORGANIZATIONS,
WHETHER IT'S A PROJECT DYNAMO
OR -- PEOPLE WANT TO HELP.
PEOPLE ARE GOOD AND CHARITABLE
ESSENTIALLY BUT SHOULDN'T FEEL
GUILTY AT ALL.
THE TRUTH IS THAT YOU WERE ABLE
TO HELP.
I THINK THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF
THE HARD CHOICES PEOPLE ARE
MAKING.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WE'VE
SEEN HAS BEEN SEPARATED FROM A
LOVED ONE.
THE WOMEN'S FROM THEIR HUSBANDS,
THEIR MOTHERS FROM THEIR
FATHERS.
AND, THE MEN FOR THEIR CHILDREN,
THEIR WIVES DEVASTATING TO THINK
THAT THIS THUG IN RUSSIA HAS
DONE NOTHING BUT DESTROY THE
LIVES OF INNOCENT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DONE NOTHING.
PEOPLE GO IN THERE WITH MEALS,
LIKE -- OR JUST SENDING MONEY TO
AND NOT DO GOOD THINGS, WE LEAD
FOR PEOPLE.
THE MORE THIS GOES ON, AND AS --
THE WORSE IT'S GOING TO GET,
AMERICANS SHOULD SAY "WE ARE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING."
WE HAVE 1.2 MILLION REFUGEES
GOING ALL OVER EUROPE.
WHERE IS THE U.N.?
ARE THEY TAKING CARE OF THESE
PEOPLE?
WHAT HOUSING DO WE HAVE?
WHAT ABOUT ORPHANAGES?
WHERE KIDS GO IN?
>> I THINK IT IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY STORY.
>> HER HUSBAND PASSED AWAY FROM
COVID LAST YEAR, SO SHE HAD BEEN
SPENDING TIME THERE, SHE WAS THE
UKRAINIAN, SO IS WITH HER
COUSINS AND WHATNOT IN A TINY
VILLAGE WHEN ALL OF THIS STUFF
HAPPENED.
WE HAD TO GET HER OUT AND GET
HER BACK THANKS TO FOX -- IT
REALLY MAKES YOU, WHAT YOU'VE
GONE THROUGH, MAKES YOU
SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING THROUGH.
THE WOMAN WHO STARTS TO CRY THE
END OF THAT VIDEO WE JUST PLAY
IT, I'M PRETTY SURE SHE SAID
AFTER THAT SHE LEFT HER HUSBAND.
THAT'S WHEN THEY ASKED "WHAT DID
YOU LEAVE BEHIND?"
THE HUSBAND, NOT ALLOWED TO
LEAVE IF THEY ARE 18-60, SO THEY
ARE TRYING TO FIGHT.
IT'S ABOUT HOW LONG THIS COULD
GO ON -- I ASKED JANE KIRBY WITH
THE PENTAGON WAS SAYING AND HE
SAID WEEKS OR MONTHS.
I THINK THAT MAY BE OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC.
I THINK IT'S POTENTIALLY YEARS,
IN TERMS OF INSURGENCY AND HOW
LONG THIS COULD GO ON.
THOSE FATHERS COULD BE SEPARATED
FROM THEIR CHILDREN FOR YEARS,
POTENTIALLY.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE IN RUSSIA,
THESE ARE THEIR RELATIVES.
THERE PEOPLE IN RUSSIA WITH
LOVED ONES WHO THEY WON'T SEE.
"UKRAINE IS PART OF RUSSIA, SO
WE SHOULD ALL BE TOGETHER."
AS IF HE WAS SAYING SOME
ALTRUISTIC THING TO GET THE
COUNTRY BACK TOGETHER FOR HIS
EGOMANIACAL VISION OF A RUSSIAN
EMPIRE THAT THEY DON'T WANT!
>> SAY GOODBYE TO HUSBAND'S
POSSIBLY FOREVER AND MAY NEVER
BE REUNITED IF YOU ARE KILLED IN
THIS WAR.
THINK OF -- THE AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWALS COME HOPING TO GET
INTERPRETERS AND PEOPLE IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, GET THEM OUT
AS MUCH AS THEY COULD.
GRATEFUL THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO
HELP.
UKRAINE IS A COUNTRY OF
44 MILLION PEOPLE, READY
1.2 MILLION ACROSS THE BORDER.
AMAZING NEIGHBOR IN ALL OF THIS.
WELCOME THEM WITH OPEN ARMS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING FOOD AND
HUMANITARIAN AID.
A WEEK AGO, PEOPLE WERE SAYING
THAT THEY HAD THREE DAYS WORTH
OF WOOD.
THEY MAY BE IN AN ORPHANAGE
WHERE THERE ARE DOZENS OR
HUNDREDS OF KIDS THAT NEED TO.
IN SOCIETY WERE EXAMINED
QUICKLY, PEOPLE CAN'T GET BASIC
THINGS LIKE FOOD AND WATER.
HUMANITARIAN PATH THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO MAKE UP WITH THE
RUSSIANS, PUTIN -- WE KNOW
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT, BUT WE
HAVE NOT SEEN MOVEMENT ON
SETTING UP THAT FLOW OF
HUMANITARIAN AID.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
PEOPLE HAVE TO LEAVE AND MAKE
THE DECISION OVERNIGHT.
THEIR FAMILIES -- TELLING A
STORY TODAY ABOUT THE
ORGANIZATION WHO IS HELPING TO
GET PEOPLE OUT.
AFTER NINE YEARS OLD, SIX
KIDS -- DROPPED THEM OFF, HAD TO
GO BACK